[Applause]
welcome to the event this afternoon it's
a great pleasure to be here to have Ken
Burns and Linda Novak and the brilliant
capacity to produce documentaries and
narratives about extremely important and
decisive events in our history I just
have a few things to say by way of
introduction the first is simply that I
can think of no more important event in
my lifetime no more defining event than
the Vietnam War and conflict and I want
to say eventually what I think about
today in light of that comment about the
defining nature of the Vietnam War in my
lifetime but I also want to say
something about the healing that has
taken place in significant part at this
university over the course of the past
number of decades and it's happened
significantly through our magnificent
program called General Studies and the
leadership of Dean Peter on our
enrollment of military vets is one of
the proudest pieces of the Columbia
identity and you will hear today from
some of them this is something that is
not only important for the good of the
country the good of the world it's not
only important because of some abstract
idea of diversity of voices it is a
truly original idea
inherent in the creation of the school
of general studies that talent capacity
come in all kinds of forms and from all
kinds of places and at all ages and I
want to give a special recognition to
the school and to Peter on for that
Peter
and the second part is the the broader
sort of issue of the military and
universities and military and Colombia
and the re-establishment of NROTC on the
campus which I was very much in favor of
because of the strong position that I
think the university took and has taken
over these years as a matter of
principle about policies such as Don't
Ask Don't Tell discrimination largely
that within the military that we had to
stand up to there was also in the
Vietnam era a widening gulf between
universities the academic world and the
military which was my mind completely
understandable at that moment but over
time had to at some point be resolved
and I think that we took a step as other
universities did in that resolution with
the reestablishment of NROTC the last
thing I want to say is just about the
war in Vietnam and the era as with any I
think defining experience it was
intertwined with many other extremely
important movements and changes in the
society and I'm thinking especially of
the civil rights movement but also the
feminist movement etc I I think in every
aspect of American life in every aspect
I think beyond this country but in every
aspect of American life you can see the
effects of those defining moments so in
my own field of the First Amendment
the defining cases are New York Times
versus Sullivan which is significantly
about civil rights and the Pentagon
Papers case which is significantly about
the war in Vietnam and that kind of
transformational moment is I think I
hope about to happen again because I
think we're entering some kind of
experiences that are like the Vietnam
War and what the civil rights movement
was against so we're seeing I think in a
very visible way and obviously I don't
have time and don't have the inclination
at the moment to spell this out in
detail but I think we are seeing in
manifestation of policies in practices
in attitudes and so on
the kinds of things that prompted the
resistance to this and the efforts to
try to change the world in the 1960s and
70s that needs to happen again today so
I see a very sharp relevance to what can
and Linnet produced when they started 10
years ago I'm sure they had this in mind
at this moment congratulations to both
of you thank you all for coming today
[Applause]
thank you all for joining us this is
really an extraordinary opportunity for
Columbia University to celebrate the
premiere of this astounding ten part
18-hour documentary on the Vietnam War
but also to spend time talking about the
issues that really do affect us
personally here on campus the whole
issue of the military and its engagement
not only with Columbia University
but with campuses around the country it
really is a privilege to have with us
Ken Burns who is without doubt one of
the greatest filmmakers this country has
ever seen
from this first documentary 1981 on the
Brooklyn Bridge which received an
Academy Award nomination to this
incredibly ambitious effort on the
Vietnam War he has made a think made us
confront our history and truly
contributed to substantive dialogue
within this country his collaborator
lanova k-- has been working with him for
30 years and they are co-producers of
the Vietnam War not only does she work
closely with Ken but she has her own
projects a two-part documentary on the
life of Ernest Hemingway which should
have been oh oh you're doing that
together okay sorry
and the bard whoa you don't don't take
that away from them no no and the one
I'm bard the bard college president okay
great is your mic working oh you're
gonna do a handheld okay okay great and
Mike Haynie
who attended Columbia in 1967 before
heading off to Harvard Law School
and following Harvard Law School a PhD
in American history at Rutgers
University
Mike was a platoon leader in Vietnam in
65 and 66 and the first cavalry of which
he was a part of was ambushed he was the
leaflet ooon and many of his men died in
that 20-hour battle
Mike was badly wounded flown back
eventually to the United States
underwent surgeries and rehabilitation
and then transition immediately back
into civilian life for the past thirty
years he's been an extraordinary teacher
but mostly engaged in working with
veterans at all levels especially those
who have been wounded and those
suffering from post-traumatic stress
mark Franklin is a current student at
the school of general studies mark began
a studies at Columbia in 2013 after have
been served in 2004 as an Cavalry Scout
which he tells me it is Army recon in
Baghdad in Najaf and in Fallujah where
he earned a Purple Heart and Bronze Star
he once again saw active duty in
Afghanistan in 2006 where the helicopter
he was on was shot down he was badly
injured and after being medevac'd to
Germany and then to Walter Reed where he
received significant medical attention
numerous surgeries he was finally able
to rejoin the civilian population and he
is majoring in environmental now
sustainable development sustainable
development
working predominantly on sort of green
urban projects which he hopes to do in
the future I'm gonna start by by asking
Ken and Lin really about the origins of
this project and the significance that
they believe it has to to us here at the
university but for broadly in the
American population then we'll move to
looking at three very short clips each
of which I hope will provoke
conversations among the panelists at the
end of the by three o'clock or so we
will move to questions from the audience
there will be microphones on each side
and we'll have your opportunity for you
to question the panelists so can get a
sense of why you began this project and
what you think after ten years this is
going to to really do for us well first
of all thank you Peter for inviting us
here we're so grateful to have the
opportunity to be on the same panel with
you and with Mark but also with our dear
friend Mike who we've gotten to know for
the last several years an extraordinary
human being we Lynn and I were making a
film on the history of the second world
war it was going to be broadcast it was
broadcast in the fall of 2007 at the end
of 2006 it seemed really clear as we
sort of looked we could see the light at
the end of the tunnel most definitely in
that war that we looked sort of beyond
and saw as the major event after the
Second World War in American history
that we really had to do Vietnam and I
said this to Lynn and she said what part
and I said all of it and we both kind of
gulped and understood that essentially
we were committing ourselves to a decade
of attention to something that is
extraordinarily fraught from that period
and even now something that we don't
like to talk about something that we
don't deal with many of us are in
hardened silos of absolute certainty
about opinions that turn out due to
recent scholarship that we've been able
to avail ourselves of wrong
upside down backwards and that also and
we didn't feel this at the time it
wasn't a motivating factor and in fact
none of our films tried to point arrows
at the present and say isn't it topical
in fact this film was finished
editorially for the most part by the end
of 2015 before Iowa caucuses if that can
help you ground you but the film is and
we understand Mark Twain is supposed to
have said that history doesn't repeat
itself but it rhymes
we're been aware since the Brooklyn
Bridge film that there are almost every
film that we've done indeed every film
that we've done rhymes in many many
startling ways with the present and
while we felt in 2006 there were pretty
evident connections with that present we
feel it potently today mass
demonstrations taking place across the
country against the current
administration a White House in disarray
obsessed with leaks a president certain
the media is lying about him and making
up stories asymmetrical warfare that
confounds the military big document
drops of stolen classified material into
the public sphere and accusations that a
political campaign reached out during
the time of the national election to a
foreign country to try to influence that
election all of that is really just
after thoughts on our part as we begin
to release a series in which we felt it
was very important that in order to be
able to have a kind of conversation
about Vietnam we had to get out of those
hardened silos or maybe even out of the
the the sand that our heads have been
ducked in like ostriches that in order
to do that we had to look at all sides
and when Americans talk about Vietnam
they almost always talk about just
themselves to go out and interview North
Vietnamese soldiers and civilians and
South Vietnamese soldiers and civilians
and Vietcong guerrillas as well as a
whole panoply of American ranges of
experience from people who knew from the
very beginning that it was wrong to
people who I presume think we should
still be there fighting the Communists
and more importantly all the gradations
in between and what we came to
understand as we've seen subtly in other
war films and certainly other films
we've done which is that that there can
be more than one truth as our slogan
says there's no single truth in war
there could be many many truths and we
try to create a space in which those
could happen and the only thing I'll say
more about this is that I think the
question that you raised Peter at the
beginning about the the Academy broadly
Columbia specifically in the military is
part of a binary world that we have been
engaged in everything to us in this
computer age and this media culture is
either right or wrong black or white red
state or blue state however you want to
configure it and we are beset by that so
many of the divisions that we experience
today
the hyper partisanship was born in the
Vietnam War and have only grown and
metastasize and festered and we sort of
feel that it might be possible as we
begin to have conversations in the wake
of the series that we've spent so long
producing that it might be possible to
find a way to reconcile sometimes
seemingly opposite things and understand
how much they share in common so we are
that's that's sort of the short history
we can actually show you the whole film
if you'd like yeah I'm here to show some
clips and have a conversation with all
of you the only thing I will say is just
sitting here and thinking about what
kind of saying and who's here and what's
happening and what the president said
earlier about what happened on college
campuses this campus in particular but
many other campuses during the time I'm
born in 1962 so when I went to college
it was over it was sort of the aftermath
there were still some smoking embers but
it was basically tamp down the the not
just violence but sort of frustration
and disintegration of our social order
that was happening was there for a
reason which was that it was the build
up of people who were taking the time to
figure out what was happening through
teachings and through trying to
understand the war we're realizing and
especially people Yuri people of college
age there were subject to the draft and
subject to going to Vietnam questioning
whether we should be there what we
should be doing was a very healthy
questioning of our leaders who were not
telling us the truth which spiraled into
something very frightening and
disturbing to a lot of people in our
country and we ended up you know by 1970
students trying to burn down the ROTC
building on a number of campuses and as
a result of that I mean this is all
history I learned from bringing on this
film
ROTC being exiled from college campuses
and right when we started this film I
had the chance to get to meet a guy who
was West Point class of 1945 and then
became an army officer and was worked
his way up to Colonel and this is
someone that Mike Kane he actually
introduced us to Robert Rowe and he had
a very distinguished military career up
to a certain point and he said that he
thought it was a terrible thing that
happened when the civilian-military
schism happened and ROTC went away from
college campuses because we were left
without our army our military being led
by people who came from places like this
and that that was tragic for our country
and so I just want to say it's really
wonderful to be here and to be
understand what's been happening in the
interim to rebuild that connection
because for all of our for our for our
country's national security we need
people who come to places like this to
be working in our military and why don't
we move to the first clip which really I
think will spark a serious conversation
about the environment of the time to
Vietnam in terms of protest this is a
clip about the major protest not only in
front of the Pentagon but an effort by
some to move into the Pentagon early 67
it was back in 1942 I was a member of a
good platoon we were on maneuvers in
Louisiana one night by the light of the
moon the captain told us to fall a river
that's how it all begun
we were knee-deep in the Big Muddy the
big fool says to push on there was a
major demonstration either in New York
or in Washington every fall in every
spring we decided that we would go to
the demonstration in Washington at the
Lincoln Memorial in the fall of 67 but
we would take as many people out of that
demonstration as we could and lead them
to the Pentagon and at the Pentagon try
to do something more militant than
simply stand around and make speeches
opposing the war which is what these
demonstrations had become and when the
time came to lead people away from the
Lincoln Memorial toward the Pentagon
50,000 people march
we were neck deep in the Big Muddy the
big fools as de cochon bill Zimmerman
now an assistant professor of psychology
at Brooklyn College had been against the
war since the beginning then we found
when we got there concentric defense
perimeters that had been set up around
the Pentagon to keep us at a distance
from the buildings we pushed against
them we tore down their fences I was
working that weekend day the secretaries
who were working in my area were
frightened to hell what these Vietnam
protesters would do they thought they
were going to come in through the
building and rape them some of them
actually came over the wall was big news
in the bush and it was a sense of
revolution
waist-deep in the Big Muddy a big fool
says to Bashar
lise deep in the Big Muddy a big fool
system of home god knows what we were
gonna do when we got in the building
some people the hippies said they were
gonna levitate the building other people
wanted to commit vandalism in the
building other people wanted to
distribute anti-war literature in the
building talked to people just the idea
of getting into the headquarters of the
United States military it was the first
time that anti-war demonstrators had
confronted active duty military
personnel we didn't consider them the
enemy we considered them victims of the
war but we began to see our own
government as the enemy we began to see
them as victims of war what's your
response to that I have them like can
you all hear me yeah I'm I can't it's
great to see so many of you I heard they
would you raise your hand if you're a
veteran just to see great well thanks
for your service and thanks for coming
this was a very very difficult part of
my life
Vietnam was a very difficult part of my
life but I came back in 1966 pretty
badly wounded was trying to sort a lot
of things out nobody had invented the
the term PTSD yet I wasn't getting any
treatment for some things that were
badly wrong going badly wrong in my life
so I decided I know what I'll do I'll go
to Columbia University for a semester in
there general school of general studies
which at that time was a little
different from what it is today helping
a lot of veterans which which I greatly
applaud but it was a place where I could
go to school for a semester before I
started law school and that was really
my first exposure to the radicalism and
the opposition to the war that had taken
over on a great many campuses and right
out here and
which I haven't been to in 50 years I
figured that out on the way over today
there were always tables and groups of
self-identified radical students
espousing one cause or another there was
always a table in opposition to the war
in Vietnam and I would inevitably be
drawn to that table and I wouldn't tell
him who I was or or that I just been
back from Vietnam because we we were
often treated poorly as that so I didn't
want them to know but I would question
the guy on what evidence he or she had
for the the things that they were saying
and sometimes these encounters ended up
in nice long ish discussions and
sometimes they didn't but that was my
first exposure and so I started to
develop a feeling toward war dissenters
and draft dodgers which was becoming an
increasing pattern and that and then
going to law school at a very
radicalized campus made me think about
harder about the Vietnam War and whether
I had made a big mistake by going so
that was the initial reaction that I had
I I just wanted to add that the
dialectic or the dynamic of the anti-war
movement is extraordinarily fluid within
our film and develops out of
internationalist anti-nuclear
proliferation combined with civil rights
combined with legitimate moral stuff I
grew up in a college campus in Ann Arbor
which had one of the first if not the
first teach-in and in the spring of 65
and so that kind of world that Mike is
describing here which is documented in
our film in another section including
the very brutal suppression of that
occupation here by the New York City
police is an important part of our film
but I wanted to say that what's so
interesting to me is how much the
returning vets began to add
like their own significant tributary to
an ongoing anti-war movement that was
changing all the time you can see in
that march on the Washington they're
saying you know bring the gi's home and
the war now they saw that as an
important central part though we do
inherit a good deal of the mistreatment
that you also feared
and had happen I think for for modern
vets the the term victim of the war
right this this phrase is it's very
different than from the Vietnam era of
course right there was a draft we all
most of the veterans here join the
military when we were already at war
right so we made that affirmative
decision to go to war so the the idea of
being a victim of it I think only comes
into view when when you look at the
desire to extend the war for as long as
it has been right this this 16 year
conflict that we're in presently you you
start to see the victimization I suppose
of military personnel when it comes to
multiple deployments over and over and
over again going back you know my first
deployment was 15 months and now of
course they're shorter but you have
people with 8 9 deployments under their
belt and that's and that's where you
become a victim not so much of the war
itself but of the political decision to
continue you know engaging in this
conflict for the length that we have I
mean I was just quickly chime in that
one of the things that really comes
through in the film and the story that
we tried to tell is there was sort of at
times when it came to things like you
know shunning soldiers or getting into
targeting returning servicemen that the
focus really needed to be on the
policymakers who are making the
decisions to perpetuate the war to keep
it going to not tell the American people
the truth and you know that dynamic sort
of got diffused with a general
frustration with everything that was
going on
that sense of revolution just sort of up
ending the whole system if you will
because there was a sense that what was
going on was devolve into something that
wasn't working and somehow we see it
again again from what Mike was just
saying that soldiers seemed to have
returning soldiers were kind of caught
in the crossfire of that and one of our
veterans says that coming home from
Vietnam was almost as traumatic as the
war itself and if you think about it
which we have for a long time we imagine
those of us who haven't been in combat
that war is about the most traumatic
thing can possibly imagine so the idea
that the Welcome Home that didn't happen
and the way that returning soldiers felt
was almost as traumatic as the war is a
profound thing to think about and I
think also that Mark's experience now
and adds another aspect to this which is
hugely important which is that in the
early days of the Vietnam War it was
staffed with people who were
volunteering you did see this as a cause
later on the draft came and I mean the
draft was always there but it was a it
became a more contentious thing one of
the things we learned among many things
not to blame the the veterans is that we
created an all-volunteer army and what
that does is it takes the American
public skin out of this game and and
that's an unfortunate thing and we can
talk about a draft or national service
and I think these are really important
things but we have to really understand
that we now have a military community 1%
of the population that suffers its
losses apart and alone from the rest of
us and therefore there is no exertion of
will by a large group of the American
polity against continuing on with the
war and that permits this intolerable
unconscionable war crime of having
people go through seven or eight or nine
deployments it's one thing if it's a
world war and you're in for the duration
I get that but when you have a kind of
perpetual war because you can have a
perpetual war the fact that we've served
rectified one aspect and created perhaps
an even bigger problem I think is
something that we ought to be addressing
and one of the things that
reintegrating the military with the
Academy or vice-versa becomes the
possibility for the rest of us instead
of conveniently putting it out of our
minds and saying as an end of a sentence
thank you for your service but rather
welcome home and what can we do for you
you become part of the conversation and
we have the possibility as a as a public
now to re-engage and reinvest ourselves
in the ultimate policy decisions that
seem to perpetually send us into war
well we you know and you alluded to it
exactly we as a country haven't been at
war since Vietnam our military has but
this the country has it and that's and
that's that's a key difference and and
we talk about the civil military divide
and this you know perpetuation of
stereotypes of military personnel and
things like that it's it is it is
exactly because the American public has
been totally insulated from this we now
have a warrior caste of people like who
fight our Wars for us we don't we don't
go to war as a nation anymore why don't
we move to the next clip which is coming
back home to college
[Music]
let's just say that being a Marine
combat veteran on a college campus in
1969 and 1970 it wasn't a real good
thing to be if you wanted to get dates
and be popular when I came home it
seemed like I didn't have anything to
give to anybody else Marine corporal
John Musgrave had very nearly died in
combat below the DMZ in the autumn of
1967 wounded in the jaw and shoulder his
ribs shattered lung pierced nerves cut
he had spent 17 months in navy hospitals
he was now studying at Baker University
in Baldwin City Kansas but wherever he
went the war was never far away
and the peace movement for a while got
real nasty calling veterans baby killers
[Music]
it did more than piss us off it broke
our hearts look they thinking you don't
turn your backs on your warriors
[Music]
I didn't trust anybody anymore just my
family
Musgraves was so hurt by the way some
people treated him that he volunteered
to return to Vietnam because of his
injuries the Marines turned him down and
asked him to help recruit men instead he
did for a time but when students asked
him questions about the war he couldn't
answer he also began to read about how
and why it was being fought I had
friends in country on a second tour and
you know I still consider myself a
Marine and and the more I read the less
I found to be able to defend our
presence there so then I I just stopped
talking everybody that's an
extraordinary powerful piece and in that
sense of conflict I presume it's
something you could both you well I'm
the thing I'll just say is that this
goes the next moment is a near suicide
on the part of John Musgrave fortunately
he's one of the great human beings that
we all we all know and and and I think
one of the things that Lynne and I
wanted to do is that wars offer an
inevitably vivifying study of human
nature and we are drawn to the conflict
and we presume that that conflict is
between armies and in fact what is so
very clear particularly in this war but
in but indeed all the wars that the very
important stories are the ones the wars
that happen the conflicts that happen
the battles that go on all the time
within human beings mike has alluded to
it Musgrave is in the middle of it right
there and that many of the people of the
80 or so people you meet in the film
Vietnamese as well as American undergo
profound psychological and emotional
changes in the course of this that might
influence their politics might not
influence their
politics but we were trying to be as
conscious and aware of those kinds of
wars those kinds of battles as we were
the the obvious ones on the battlefield
which were not neglecting their there
but I just want to say there's an
there's an interesting tension with a
narrative but between that interior and
the exterior Wars yeah III in watching
the clip and being here's just the
context is everything and I was just
reminded of the fact that even to this
day there's debate about you know what
was said to soldiers coming home where
people spit on were they not books have
been written about this it's a
conversation that's ongoing with each
camp having it's sort of you know locked
in position and clearly just from the
visual imagery you see that there's
enormous tension and criticism being
directed at soldiers and I was reminded
of the very thoughtful words of a woman
that our colleague Sarah bot Stein our
producer interviewed who went to
Columbia who's here in 68 her name is
Nancy Lieberman you'll see her in the
film at different points but she says
you know we were kids too the soldiers
were teenagers and we were teenagers and
when you're that age you just your
experiences are heightened and you
everything is just very important and
this wasn't a time when there was a lot
at stake but she's sort of in looking
back was able to kind of recognize and
regret some of the things that she said
and that were done but in the spirit of
trying to affect change that people
really believed in I think it's
important was important for us as
filmmakers and for anyone watching the
film to kind of honor that - that the
people who protested the war we're
trying to do what they thought was the
right thing and our film really calls
into question and hopefully we get to
think about what does it mean to be a
patriot in a country where you're not
sure the government is doing the right
thing so I think we've created it
hopefully what we've tried to do is a
big enough space in this film for these
kind of a different kind of conversation
to happen about this time and we've seen
it in the film and I think we're seeing
it in the reactions to it so far one
thing I remember very well that happened
right here at
along these lines was I was a mixer one
Friday night trying to meet somebody to
go out with and some guy there figured
out that I was a veteran and I was
recently back and he typed up at one
point grabbed my shoulder and said so
how does it feel to have been attached
devoted to an organization whose
business was to kill women and children
I was kind of stunned by that and I my
inner voice was saying Michael you have
to speak up you have to push back on
this I understand how this young man
feels but I so I did I said you know
what I was there early in the war
granted early in the war American units
were more together we the 1st Cavalry
Division was the first Army division
sent over it was a good military unit it
practice traditional military values
which incur with which include honor and
courage and fair treatment of prisoners
fair treatment of civilians I never saw
an atrocity in fact on a couple of
occasions I asked my men to take risks
personal risks so that they wouldn't
shoot at or maybe kill the wrong people
and that's what I brought back and you
know screw you anyway but that was the
kind of conflict and and like Jen said
there and Lynn there are books written
about how exactly we're Vietnam veterans
treated I was for the most part treated
okay especially when I was in my little
hometown in New Jersey people who were
absolutely opposed to the war treated me
civilly and even kindly my family
certainly did but there was also a lot
of other stuff if there is a oh no I'm
done
so I I think 68 you know there was a
protest here at Columbia no there there
was certainly a hyper awareness of the
war in Vietnam and I think today we
suffer from a hyper lack of awareness
right so I'm rarely met with any
animosity on Columbia's campus most of
the time it's it's it's curiosity people
just don't know people don't have
immediate family members who have served
in the military I mean I have I was
asked one time in class what it was like
to murder women and children right and I
I did not handle it as diplomatically as
you did I said I haven't proved that
sherry with this age my response was
that the kids were double points and at
least I ate them afterward but that was
not well received but you know it was
like it got me very angry you know it's
like you did but then of course in
retrospect and I feel very guilty about
that reaction that I had it is is what
you were alluding to is a 19 year old
student and so it's just a fundamental
misunderstanding of what it is to be a
soldier right to prosecute a war as an
individual as an individual implement of
war there are so many layers and so many
things that go into being a soldier that
don't involve killing and generally
killing is at the very end of a long
list of things and so to even assume
that because someone has been in the
military they've taken someone's life
betray is a fundamental misunderstanding
of what military service is but but
aren't you both hyper aware like John
Musgrave about what can I share what can
I share or in what context do I share I
mean is that true I may be completely
wrong on this but my heart was broken to
four
same reason that you saw John Musgrave
say his heart was programmed saying an
interesting story when I got to law
school after a year or so a lot of my
close friends figured out I was a vet
and and and that I was turning against
the war gradually and so one of them one
day was a active anti-war dissident
liked to go out and Mark said Michael
you got a couple who had a lead or next
March wouldn't it be great to have the
Vietnam veteran has turned against the
war and I thought about it and I said
you know what I can't do that I didn't
come back that long ago and I lost on
one day in about two minutes ten guys
that I'd spent five months living with
mostly undereducated working-class guys
who I loved I came to love and and they
gave it all and even if I end up
absolutely opposing the war I'm not
going to go I'm not going to break faith
with them but you can see that the
conflict the inner tension that that
kind of thing
provokes yeah good question yeah no I
think of course I am hyper aware of the
war and the current war but and and
there is there is a certain fiduciary
responsibility on the part of veterans
particularly at Columbia it's part of
the reason why we're here right this
veteran integration into the regular
undergraduate classes we have a life
experience that Columbia University
values and we bring stuff to the
classroom that your typical
undergraduate student doesn't so yeah I
think I think it's very important to
talk about it and there are certain
things that I won't talk about but I
think most importantly for from the
modern campus it's just having an
interaction a normal interaction with a
veteran so we're just normal people you
know I I'm a huge Star Wars fan and like
you know I I like soccer like you know
it's like a normal guy
and and I think that that's that's very
very key to two veteran integration on
the modern campus one of our Marines in
the film says that we're not the
dominant species on the planet because
we're nice and that people like to
complain that the military takes young
men and turns them into killers and he
said I would only suggest that it's
finishing school and I think that what
we do in the isolation of our military
not just in the circumstances of an
all-volunteer military now but in the
circumstances of how we won't confront
our own culpability with our
predilection towards violence makes it
super hard what we move to the final
cliff which really captures I think in
an incredibly poignant way what happens
when it becomes almost impossible to
process what the experience has been pts
in Vietnam can I just say that that all
of the people that you've met in these
clips we've already met and gotten to
know we probably know where they went to
high school we know where they went what
their parents did in World War two we
know their experience and we have been
with them so this clip particularly but
also the others we've seen are the
culmination of many interactions with
these individuals that we've come to
know like family members within the
context of the narrative of this film
[Music]
[Applause]
I remember I was with one of my
daughters in an intersection and some
guy came up behind me and blasted the
horn when I came to my senses I was on
the hood of his car
about trying to kick his windshield in
and I went she and there's people all
over looking I mean this is crazy this
is crazy and then I start going well
this is weird and so I slink back to my
car and you know retard she's about four
looking at me wow what's that all about
what is that all about I had no idea I
did no idea that was even related to the
war it is as old as war itself the
ancient Greeks called it divine madness
it was soldier's heart in the Civil War
shellshock during the First World War
and combat fatigue in the second
following Vietnam it was given a new
name post-traumatic stress disorder PTSD
and what you learn is that PTSD doesn't
go away but now someone honks the horn
and it startles me I'm still my heart
rates still gonna go up and it'll be
there for five minutes and I'm like this
but ten nine it's just some asshole ways
have a bad day we're eight seven six
it's not knowing shooting actually
you're safe at seven six five four three
two one and I can control it
whereas I couldn't do it before I didn't
understand what was going on adding to
the pain many veterans felt was their
country's eagerness to forget the war
there were few parades in many ways
everyone came home from Vietnam
alone
[Music]
when I got home and my mom and dad were
there and my brothers and sisters my
wife and our embracing and I couldn't
relate to my wife or my mother what I
had seen what I had done in Vietnam I
could have talked to my brothers about
it but they they knew I didn't want to
and so just the something unsaid you
know
welcome back fence he'd been through the
wringer but welcome back for me that's
an incredibly moving piece but it also
raises an issue that that's come up
regularly in my discussion with students
who are veterans but in this climate
where there is such a divide the effort
to really reach out to people suffering
from post-traumatic stress creates an
image of the returning veteran as a
ticking time bomb
and that and that's the legacy of
Vietnam I mean that really sort of
stereotype yes I think so I mean there
were soldiers in World War one like we
say you know who never were functional
again World War two as well but it
wasn't discussed in a productive way in
society in Vietnam veterans you know
demanded treatment demanded a
recognition and acknowledged that
something wasn't right but not every
Vietnam veterans suffer from PTSD the
vast majority do not and the vast
majority are productive citizens and you
know contributing members of society so
they're one of the things we hope our
film does is to kind of undo those
stereotypes but on the other hand
there's also room we don't doesn't have
to be all or nothing right so I think
we've tried to also at least raise the
fact that the lingering effects of being
at war profound but even my experience
here what's been so really incredibly
moving and impressed
is even the students for whom this
becomes an issue the vast majority are
able to work through it and learn how to
manage it may be because they have clear
goals that they want to achieve they see
they have a real future but it doesn't
have to be seen as this once you've got
it you're damaged goods for the rest of
your life you should talk about the work
that you've been did with Bob and it's
amazing yes thanks that's that's a good
dilemma to be thinking about what what
is PTSD it's a very vaguely and broadly
defined clinically defined diagnosis and
it's said to mimic other things like
bipolar disorder and addictive illness
and it does sometimes but it's different
for every soldier and some soldiers seem
to get through traumatic experiences
okay others do not
the therapeutic community is still
debates endlessly why this happens or it
happens in a worse way to some and and
others so I've I'm sure that I've
suffered from a little bit of PTSD I'm
also sure that I have not suffered
nearly as much as many of my fellow vets
and so one of the things I under the
leadership of Bob Rowe who who Lynn
mentioned earlier is a retired Special
Forces colonel he started a program
joint program with outward-bound which
some of you may know something about and
the VA where we would take out into the
field for a week on a little outdoor
expedition that veterans who were
diagnosed with PTSD and were inpatients
in a VA hospital and we learned over a
period of years how best to do this some
people thought you're crazy to take a
bunch of nut cases out in the woods it's
going to bubble up all the stuff that
happened to them in Vietnam it's going
to replicate some of that experience
walking along in a column
in the woods but it didn't turn out that
way and but the it helped a lot of
people we did that program for 15 years
and we put about a thousand veterans who
were patients at a VA through it but
what I wanted to the point I wanted to
make with that is I found whatever was
wrong with me and there was several
things I drank way too much I had
flashbacks I had the anger one I can't
think of rage whatever I had if I could
deal with it best by reaching out to
other other vets who were worse off than
I was and helping them it's this it's
not rocket science it's not a new
technique it's probably as old as as the
human race and warfare but it really
helped me to reach out I think the army
does and the other military branches do
much better job at treating that's with
with traumatic brain injury PTSD and any
other ailments that all vets suffer from
some some bets suffer more than others
so that's my thought on that I think
what the the line that really strikes me
from that clip is that everyone came
home alone yeah in a sense right there's
no finality to it I mean there ended up
being a very dramatic end to the Vietnam
War but in a lot of ways not much has
changed you sort of come back you know
it's my instance you know the lot of
guys I served with remained in for a
period of time and yeah I I came back
and there wasn't a lot of you know there
was no fanfare there was no whatever it
was just people out well you know
welcome back Oh glad you're alive and
you know there there is still that that
sense of isolation I think is persistent
but with that being said I just just
being aware of
fast amount of resources that currently
exists to help veterans deal with PTSD
or TBI is and any other number of things
that that exist is is great but you
always do run that risk of when you push
too hard on issues like that you you can
end up painting all veterans with this
broad brush and so it's it's a balance
and it's a balance that I think that I
think we're still working to figure out
I agree I think the diagnosis of PTSD is
a wonderful and very important thing but
it's also got an aspect to it that's
negative I mean we made a film on the
second world war and there are many more
people suffering from PTSD from the
Second World War than from the Viet Nam
just by the sheer numbers of it but the
kind of culture it was the sense of
unambiguous about the cause the lack of
protests the coming home all mass with
great celebration was hugely important
to that but it nevertheless wasn't there
but having the more poetic things of the
soldier's heart or the divine madness or
shell-shocked or combat fatigue giving
it a diagnosis then of course is the
broad brush and I think there is an
aspect of it as good as it is to have
the clinicians thinking about it and
studying it and applying it in other
places it still it doesn't yet do it I
mean you yourself are pretty pointed in
the film something I would not give away
in a thousand years the last word of our
film but to have Mike's experience about
what you what what what in the end you
can do with it you know just like an
alcoholic you are an alcoholic forever
period that's me there's no there's no
there's no half life to that there's no
half life to that oh why don't we begin
to open open it up to questions
don't be mics on either side so you have
to stand
to one of the mics great the ground
rules are please be extremely brief
because we want to get as many questions
in as possible so don't make lengthy
statements it should be up question
secondly we may not be able to get
through everyone so I want to apologize
early about that but let me start while
people are lining up asking a quick
question what do you think about the
difference between how the media
operated during Vietnam in contrast to
Iraq and Afghanistan how has that helped
solidify this divide where in Vietnam
every night we saw combat we saw there's
several points at play here one is the
access that journalists had during the
Vietnam War which was pretty much
unfettered and uncensored so and there
was the best journalists in the world
from all over the world
sort of converged on Vietnam to get this
story 200 journalists were killed in the
course of the war from all around the
world to bring us back some of the
images that we know so well and to take
risks so the American people and people
all around the world had images of the
war up close and personal though they
had never seen before and it wasn't like
every night was full of blood and guts
and sort of what we would call war porn
just you know horrible violent it wasn't
that it was just that there was not a
government control there was no
government narrative of the war that was
able to be consistent much as the
government tried to do that there was
constant frustration we hear President
Johnson and President Nixon to President
Kennedy but moaning the fact that they
can't control what the press is saying
and that they don't like the way the
coverage is slanted the way they see it
because it's not telling the story they
want and things have evolved that the
one of the lessons the military learned
was never to give the press that kind of
access again so we don't see
what's happening without a lot less a
lot more restriction on it and that has
a huge effect what we even know let
alone
you know our media landscape and budgets
and risks and what's important and if
like Ken was saying if our whole
country's not involved and what's the
imperative to cover the war what's the
relevance to the rest of people so there
are many different aspects of that so
why don't we start with you tell us your
name and your affiliation
hi I'm Theo Mullen applause I'm a PhD
student in political science here at
Columbia it seems to me that perhaps
just as in the early years of Vietnam
that there's a pretty sustained
bipartisan consensus in Washington that
weighs in favor of military intervention
might also account for why Afghanistan
war in Afghanistan has sustained itself
across three three presidencies now I
wondered where you think the opposition
or the the place for anti intervention
exists today in American politics I
don't think an effective anti-war
opposition at the highest political
level exists very much and that's a big
disappointment to me I think one of the
reasons for is the divide that we've
been talking about very few of today's
high-level politicians high-level
cabinet members the President himself
have any military experience at all they
don't understand what an army can do and
what it can't do and and and so what
they ask it to do a lot of a lot of
impossible things so I'm I'm a little
gloomy about that however I think this
is an arena where average folks like you
and me Theo can can constantly express
our views by calling our representative
sounds silly I live in Vermont we happen
to have a pretty good
congressional delegation on that issue
both our senators and our single
representative are very much opposed to
Wars as a general way to fix problems
and the wars were in now but I would say
that the problem is unlike right after
World War two were you you've probably
had hundreds of congressmen and Senators
who would serve who've been a part of
the army and people would look around in
their community and there'd be lots of
vets walking around that they could talk
to and ask about the next war that we
were considering getting into Lane Korea
that needs to be pumped up I think we
can do it as a society I don't think
it's going to be done at the highest
political level it just isn't yeah it's
it's pretty much exactly that you know
there's we don't have we don't exist in
a in a culture right now we don't we're
your neighbors are getting drafted your
brother your uncle whoever we don't have
people hopping the border to Canada
there's there just isn't this this
national outcry about it it's it's a
thing that the military is doing
meanwhile we're here we're okay with
that so yeah it it doesn't penetrate it
seems like the the outrage doesn't
penetrate to the highest echelon of our
government simply because the outrage
isn't there so yes over here I I'm
Philip diving my first year GS vet near
Columbia former Army Combat camera so
that kind of leads into my my question
as a storyteller I always start with you
know three words or one sentence of why
I'm doing something or why I'm telling a
story so I have this opportunity that
when I asked you know you guys obviously
there's a meant amount of takeaways and
after watching this this film but if
there could be one takeaway whether it's
a thought a point of view or a hope for
a few the future what would you task
everybody in this room to take away Wow
okay well I think I was gonna toss this
to Mike in just a minute because he has
something to say about that but um you
know I guess one of the things we've
tried to do is to really to represent as
many points to do as possible as Ken
said earlier and in listening to some of
the conversation about what it's like
for veterans to come home and not being
able to speak because there's not a
place for that it's been a great
exercise in humility for us to talk to
people from every political persuasion
every kind of background in America and
in Vietnam people who won the war people
who lost the war just a whole range of
people and to just be present and listen
with an open mind and not judge and
really try to understand what the person
were speaking to was trying to tell us
about their experience that has been
that's not easy it's always you're
always thinking what do I think but when
I do but that has been life-altering for
all of us working on this film I think
and so it's not really a lesson
specifically of the Vietnam War but more
how to understand ourselves in the world
in the context of what we're talking
about today at that that's what I would
chime in listen compromise reconcile
almost as quick
whenever what I would like to see this
film do is whenever we as a country are
on the point of deciding to get into
another war we need to calculate the
inevitable recurring historical costs of
war they always happen the costs always
have to be paid but that's almost never
discussed at the beginning of the were
look at this this film
lets us look intimately at damaged human
beings Americans Vietnamese damaged or
dead human beings destroyed landscapes
destroyed property none of that was in
my mind when I decided to go over and I
don't think was in the minds of any of
our leader so I I congratulate Lin and
Ken and their team who have done such a
marvelous job making us look at the
costs before hopefully we we get into
another
yeah thank you yeah there's Crosby
Kistler I'm GS class of nineteen
recently a Dean had submitted an email
kind of boss personally objecting to the
presence of Jag officers on campus and I
guess I'm wondering as to why this
resistance still exists and what we can
do to rectify it now you should say what
what the point was that be emailed the
point was that it was in objection to
what what was termed military policy and
against against gender discrimination no
transgender mostly yeah I think it's
it's I read the email and of course it
was it was very curious to me because it
because it's one of those things that
that we've talked about painting the
military the broad brush and it's this
fundamental misunderstanding of just how
the military operates I think is that
the current administration's decision to
ban transgender people from serving in
the military is a political decision
it's not a military decision it's not
something that a bunch of generals came
up with it is just straight follows
anymore and and and it's unfortunate to
hear something like that say that it's
the military's ban on it it's not a
military band it's a political ban and I
think they most particularly within the
Jag Corps there is an understanding that
you need to protect the rights of
minorities and I think the military the
modern military does a very good job at
that but unfortunately the reality in
which we operate is that we operate
under political whims and I think you
know the military response to it wasn't
all right transgendered people are a
band it's gonna drag our feet on it
implementing this policy and there's
been a I think very public dragging feet
on the point of the military cell is a
little disappointed to have a Dean as
particularly the Dean of the law school
who understands these separations of
powers and how the government functions
still want to paint the military as this
discriminatory organization and in a
broader stroke there is a sin to
certainty and I think that no
institution is immune to it and that we
ought to be on guard about the certainty
that comes and from from people's points
of view and that's part of the hardened
silos that I'm talking about and these
are not hardened silos that the military
necessarily is in but but all of us are
in and I think when wherever we find
ourselves absolutely certain
particularly about a historical event I
would just invite you to realize that
there is the opposite is also true and
we need to be kind of aware of that and
and I I think the Academy for its part
has to sort of let go of some very very
easy simple tropes that does what you do
in war which is you make you objectify
the enemy then you make the other
inhuman and in doing that everything is
all very simple and it's all very clear
and it permits you to do the kind of
fighting but it's also hugely dangerous
and part of the PTSD one small aspect of
it is how do you return to a world in
which you've now made something very
very elementally simple and it's not
that at all never was that my name is
jay Albin I'm a retired officer and
auditor at the college um the civilian
anti-war movement in the Vietnam time
the great attention enough inspiration
from the GIS I walk from the coffee
shops in the newspapers and they have
people who formed a WOL communities in
Canada and in Sweden were you able to
cover that and can you say what you
assess was the importance of the gi
anti-war movement yes we you we chart
the evolution of soldiers gradually
becoming more and more adamantly
outspoken against the war that's part of
the story that we tell in the film but
there were the coffee houses in the
newspapers in there and the activities
and the throwing of medals at the White
House yes you will see you will see a
good deal of that in the film do you
know how much of an influence or how
much of the value that was watch the
movie I think honestly I mean I think
it's we don't want to boil it down to
something we can explain here but it
suffice to say it's definitely part of
the story you know one of the most
reprehensible memos that comes out of
the war is a secret memo that was then
made public about that the the reason
why we were in Vietnam was seventy
percent to save face twenty percent to
counteract the Chinese and ten percent
to help the Vietnamese people now the
public relations is exactly the opposite
of that without ever admitting to saving
face so we would be terribly remiss if
we could quantify what the effects of
any given thing was in fact we'd like to
try to put as many of these given things
in and understand that over time the
majority of American people first saw
that the war was something we shouldn't
have gotten into then something that was
something we should get out of as
quickly as we can and then something
that should end right away and we chart
that and there are lots of different
reasons why bringing home a coffin of
your high school quarterback is a really
big thing in parts of this country
losing friends having your son eligible
for a draft when the deferments were
ended and it's just a lottery these are
things the activism of
people soldiers included in places that
had happened here and in Canada and
indeed across the is something important
but we would we would be as fraudulently
remiss if we were to somehow quantify it
as not and did in his memo my name is
Ravi de Silva I'm a psychiatrist at the
Medical Center and also in the Navy
Reserve we'd like to ask you a question
that sort of spans the history of film
or your filmmaking from the Civil War to
the world war two films to this one I
think there's a really fascinating
evolution of exploring the American
character based on what you've learned
over that trilogy in some sense what do
you think should be part of the dialogue
that we engage with as a nation
concerning both engagement around the
current war and and what are the next
steps for us if we were to avert these
types of interventions going forward wow
what a wonderful question and I'll let
Lynn answer - I think the mic
essentially answered your question a
second ago with regard to the fact that
for some reason human beings go to war
for some reason human beings also forget
the cost of war and they romanticize it
and they sentimentalize it and the
barnacles of that sentimentality and
crust around it we call the second world
war the good work come give me a break
this is the worst war ever the greatest
Cataclysm in human history it killed 60
million people and it's a good war well
that only comes from Vietnam because
Vietnam wasn't so good right but the
civil war itself is smothered with the
gallant bloodless you know stuff of the
lost cause and not what it was really
about slavery right so in all of the
wars I find an unbelievable uncanny
disappointing but also at times
exhilarating similarity between what's
going on particularly between Vietnam
and the Civil War there's the kind of
oppositional stuff is is very similar so
to me I just think human beings have to
sometimes be reminded as as as Micah
said better than any of us here of what
the cost is I'll tell you that when the
Civil War series came out in late
September
1990 a month and a half earlier Saddam
Hussein had invaded Kuwait by the time
we came to our national broadcast
something like eighty-five percent of
the American people who with a few
exceptions the Marine Barracks in Beirut
a couple of other things hadn't been at
war in an awfully long time we're super
excited to go to war eighty-five percent
of the American public was actually
chomping at the bit and after the civil
war played which is just a story in
black-and-white photographs of Americans
killing other Americans that appetite
declined by a quarter wish it was more
but we consider that our best review and
I think that's what Mike is is implying
that if we're going to do this I mean
all of this discussion we ought to have
skin in the game and not just trust the
warrior class to do the work for us in
the mapa well they'll take it up we've
got the best millet whatever it is but
we also have to have the kind of
conversations that we just don't have
because we are easily whipped up into a
frenzy of the the salacious positive
aspects of what war could do you know we
can win we can whip them we can kill
them they'll be dead we'll be good you
know all of that sort of stuff and I'm
shocked continually by our species
overwhelming desire to head in that
direction at the drop of a hat I did my
PhD thesis on the effect of being in a
civil war on a group of Union soldiers
that were heavily engaged and the first
thing I learned researching that is
nobody is cared enough to research this
we know what happened to the mucky-mucks
the the Colonels and the generals and
the political leaders lots have been
written but we don't know what happened
to the average soldier average american
soldier north or south in a civil war
after he came back from war
and what I try to demonstrate is these
men came back and were overwhelmingly
broken diseased badly wounded in pain
men and they lived if they lived very
long at all
they died that way the only help they
got with community organizations
churches wives so and there was such
enthusiasm as tenda said going into that
war both sides were sure they're gonna
win quickly and they would come out and
actually watch battles at the beginning
well look how it turned out it turned
out like every war does with broken
people and broken hearts and that's a
course we need to understand and talk
about before we get into war thanks for
the question absolutely all right George
Van Dam San Columbia University trustee
in making your film we get a sense that
you look through the prism of the Civil
War World War One World War two and then
current current conflicts but I heard
little about Korea and how that might
have informed you especially given the
current situation in Korea and which may
well be the next war well we finished
our film in 2015 before the Iowa
caucuses and before what's going on
right now I would say that of all of the
wars that inform our film properly Korea
is second only to the Second World War
only because so many of our Vietnam vets
parents fought in the Second World War
and you can feel it you know behind
their motivations and their drives early
on but we are sir not in the business of
political commentary we are actually
trying to answer a simple question what
happened and that means we have to stay
I mean our film begins in 1858 passes
through the Korean War it's a hugely
important moment for why we are in
Vietnam and we say so and then the first
episode ends and this would have been
available to you on Sunday night
it ends with the Kennedys inauguration
and we're plowing forward from there but
it though it ends now
the last bit of sort of granular
historical data is the fall of Saigon so
we're less interested in fighting past
Wars and future Wars than having us try
to come to terms with the vast amount of
new information that's available from
new scholarship but also from the
testimony of the extraordinarily
courageous people who fought in it or
fought against the war who populate our
film thank you hi um thank you so much
for this my name is Nadia I'm a
professor of anthropology so in the
opening one of the things you said one
to break this sorry is was that part of
the project of this film obviously I
mean key to the project was telling it
from various viewpoints and one things
you said was because almost all this
talk every time as Americans talk about
Vietnam we almost always talk about the
Americans and in fact going to had a
chance to see it obviously but sort of
telling the story from the perspective
of various Vietnamese public seems like
key so my question is about today
because one could say we don't we barely
talk about the wars in Iraq and
Afghanistan but when we do we only talk
about the Americans so I guess I'm
curious as to why the three clips you
chose to present us we're all well let's
just explain that the theme of this
event was the civilian military divide
that's what we were here to talk about
we could have spent an equally
interesting conversation about
Vietnamese perspectives Vietnamese
you'll have to see the film honestly
it's but we just had to out of 18 hours
pick a few clips to sponsor this
particular conversation but everywhere
we go we've been talking at great length
about why we wanted to incorporate as
many Vietnamese perspectives as possible
so when you task Peter yet but should on
the theme talk about discuss offline you
can blame me well I also think you need
to get to that and watch TV
you know episode three tonight
and and then it'll it'll dry it'll
parachute you right into all of that
experience but but I just think since
you're raising I mean it's you know it
does speak to this question about how P
remember Wars and what Mike was saying
about how we just jump in without
knowing the cost and in our many trips
to Vietnam you know that has been an
overcurrent theme there even more so
than here the Vietnamese lost three
million people out of 30 million a
million soldiers on the winning side and
250 thousand on the losing side plus can
add up the rest at least that many
civilians and in Vietnam today the
conversation doesn't really happen about
the war at all except as sort of a you
know grand narrative with no people in
it it's so and when we went there and
said we want to make a thought about the
human experience of the Vietnam War from
all sides we were welcomed because that
conversation hasn't been happening and
because there's an interest now in
reckoning with the true cost of the war
for them and we have some we think quite
revelatory testimony from many different
Vietnamese who were soldiers and
civilians about exactly how does one
make meaning out of tragedy on this
scale and just because we're here I'll
just say the film has been subtitled
into Vietnamese and it's streaming on
the PBS website in English Spanish and
Vietnamese and is available to be
watched in Vietnam and we had almost as
many streams in Vietnam as we did here
my name is Andrew Marcus I'm Columbia
College class of 2019 I really love your
films that had a huge impact on me I
wrote part of my Columbia application
about baseball in the West but I was
curious given the fact that this topic
at hand has much less consensus then on
the subject and some of your other films
how did you go about deciding to
dedicate screen time to certain
viewpoints this is exactly it so you
know there is for the most part
or better yet apparently consensus about
some stuff press the surface on all of
that stuff and there's not consensus but
you're absolutely right for the argument
Vietnam there's no consensus
but what's developed since we decided to
ignore it or be absolutely certain about
what our position is whetted more to
argument than to fact you know why
didn't you know if we'd only taken out
our picture in the 6th inning instead of
the 7th we would have won that game to
which the answer is yes but you didn't
and you lost and what more can I say
that we have been able to draw from 20
or 30 different scholars more if you
don't count the people who didn't come
to our New Hampshire editing room
definitely more to form the the
narrative of this and so we can distill
and kind of apprehend a at least a
scholarly consensus about things and
these are military historians as well as
academic historians or historians of
Public Policy or of different
ministrations or what elamericans
whatever it might be and we've spent the
10 years doing that and I'm not saying
we're offering now a version of what
happened as I said at the beginning we
try to create a space in which we could
have all of that lack of consensus sort
of turned on itself in a positive way
and permit us to see the war that that
that everybody's view has validity and
and that we're not going to make anybody
wrong here because of course consensus
is about saying we believe that 1 in 1
is 2 right we're absolutely as a matter
of fact we just want to say that 1 in 1
is 2 but I would ask everyone here who's
been influenced by art or by
relationship or by faith or by sex or by
whatever it is that one on one can equal
3 and in fact maybe the reason why all
of us are here is that we're looking for
that moment when one and one becomes
three so what we did is we absolve
ourselves of the responsibility to in a
boring in rote way proclaim a new
orthodoxy about Vietnam and instead
permitted Vietnam to just talk to us
with all its voices thanks so much
hi decided you know no we're getting
short on time so okay
I'm Evan toreano I'm a visiting history
PhD student from the CUNY Graduate
Center my questions actually mostly for
Mike but I guess for the panel more
generally so I was in your Vietnam War
course at Trinity College just about 18
months ago and I was yes kind of yes
yeah
curious how you approached kind of that
that task with these two very different
perspectives of being uh being a veteran
and being a trained academic historian
and maybe more broadly if you could
meditate on kind of the place of the
veterans perspective in academic in
academic history thank you so first how
did you evaluate me for the clock that's
a great and what are your office hours
yeah that's that's a great question and
to answer it briefly I decided at the
outset to trying obviously to try not to
make the course about me and and to keep
my war stories at a very low level over
time I I inched into telling more and
more of my own stories to illustrate
what I thought were you know
historically relevant and important
things to learn and as you remember I
got some encouragement for that from the
students I asked in class would you like
to hear a fuller version of my war story
I'm not going to do it in class but if
you want to meet me at 6:00 this evening
and and have pizza well I'll tell you
everything you can ask any questions you
want so that's how I handle it it is
never an easy thing for any academic to
keep himself or herself out of what
they're teaching but the class was very
respectful and very curious and I ended
up thinking you know they want to hear
some of the stories because the stories
are important that Ken and Lynn are
living embodiments of that proposition
so anyway thank you thank you for
identifying you and our final question
yeah sorry no we're short on time I'm
Margaret Lane I'm a recent MSW graduate
from Columbia School of Social Work
I believe you guys might have touched on
it but I kind of just wanted to ask
directly
specifically kenan lin what were your
hopes and specifically the lessons that
we would kind of gain from these series
and its applicability to current day
situations but also are there
limitations to the applicable to you to
these current day situations as smart
kind of mentioned to our modern veterans
and how different the circumstances are
I'll let Lin answer that but I just
preface by saying that I think that
history is the best teacher it arms you
in spectacular ways to sort of confront
and deal with the present but history
does not repeat itself Mark Twain is
right we're not condemned to repeat what
we don't remember George Santayana who
is most often credited with that it's a
wonderful phrase but Ecclesiastes may
have it better what has been will be
again what has been done will be done
again there's nothing new Under the Sun
which suggests that human nature doesn't
change unfortunately and that we will it
super imposes itself over the seemingly
seemingly random chaos of events and
that we can perceive patterns and motifs
and themes we can hear the rhymes and
the echoes perceive and feel almost
palpably the ghosts but there is a
strong limitation to being able to do
that in fact the greatest criticism
about war when you abstracted into
tactics and strategy is that you always
fight the current war with the exhibit
the with the what you learned from the
last war and that's true of human beings
in relationships and in in life and so I
would caution about a kind of a direct
one-to-one as incredibly dazzling as a
list of similarities might be they are
just that similarities however the
engagement with that past teaches you a
great deal about how to negotiate
a complicated present no I think that's
a wonderful way to end to end our
conversation no I I really honestly yeah
what would I thank you all
[Laughter]
[Applause]
thank you Ken Thank You Lynn thank you
Mike
Thank You Marv thank you all for being
here I hope this will stimulate
increased conversations our guests
however have to be whisked to another
event so sadly they can't stay but enjoy
the rest of your day
thank you really this great